برايك ما اهم التداعيات لكل هذه الخلافات
التي نشهدها وكان اجتماع المجلس الوزاري
المصغر هذه الليله قد كشف عمق هذه الازمه
وهذه الانقسامات
يعني اخي سفيان يعني لا ابالغ ان قلت لك
ان هذه الخلافات تاخذ يعني مساحه ايه من
الوقت والاهتمام والنقاش في اسرائيل اكثر
بكثير مما تاخذه الحرب الحاليه التي توصف
بالحرب الوجوديه ل اسرائيل وخاصه انه انه
حاله عدم الانسجام الحالي والتي تطورت الى
اختلافات ثم الى خلافات
عميقه تطال يعني ليس فقط المؤسسات القائمه
انما على صعيد الاشخاص لا يوجد انسجام
الان ما بين الاشخاص سواء
داخل المركب السياسي او داخل ما بين
المستوى السياسي والعسكري والامني وهذا
يعني يتزامن مع مسالتين الاولى تراجع يومي
باستمرار بمنظومه ثقه المجتمع اليهودي به
المنظومه السياسيه والامنيه برمتها ثم عدم
قدره اسرائيل جيش شا ام منها مخابراتها
على تحقيق شيء ممكن ان يعدل بالمشهد في في
في قطاع غزه وان يرمم الصوره السوداويه
والسلبيه التي هشمت صوره اسرائيل بالسابع
من اكتوبر وما تلى السابع من اكتوبر كل ه
المتغيرات معا اوصلتنا الى هذه الحاله
والتي ادت الى حاله من ت خبط باتجاهين
الاول حول كيفيه استمرار الحرب بالشمال
وبالجنوب والمرحله الثانيه والثالثه وكل
هي التفاصيل التي فرضت على الامريكي ان
يتواجد بالمنطقه وان لا يغيب و وقدوم وزير
الخارجيه باليومين القادمين لاكبر دليل
على ذلك وهو عدم ثقته في ان ما تريده
الاداره الامريكيه يتم تنفيذه بالميدان
بالتالي يفضل ان يكون موجود هنا لمتابعه
الامور عن كثب وعن قرب هذا جانب الجانب
الاخر انه بدا واضح لخصوم بنيامين نتنياهو
اولئك الذين يرون ان لا مصلحه لاسرائيل
بالبقاء بغزه بعد الحرب سواء عسكريا او
استيطانيا والذين على تنسيق تام مع
الاداره الامريكيه بهي الجزئيه يرون ان
نتنياهو ؤجل ويماطل في
انعقاد اجتماعات لمناقشه غزه ما بعد الحرب
لخلق
واقع يتم
يعني خلق واقع جديد بموجبه يتعذر احداث اي
تغيير من حيث و وتبين بشكل واضح انه هنالك
ترتيبات سريه ما بين نتنياهو وشركاؤه
باليمين الديني لعوده الاستيطان الى غزه
هذا ما لا تريده الاداره الامريكيه وما لا
تريد اغلبيه المنظومه السياسيه في اسرائيل
باستثناء حلفاء بنيامين نتنياهو بالتالي
ارى انه انه انه بقاء الامور بشكلها
الحالي سيؤدي الى خروج جنتس بالمرحله القا
قادمه من من مجلس الحرب هو وا ايزنكوت وفي
حال خروجهم بالتاكيد سيشكل هذا
مدخلا لجنت والذي بدا واضح بالايام
الماضيه انه يريد تمييز ذاته عن بنيامين
نتنياهو لا يريد ان يربط مستقبله بمستقبل
بنيامين نتنياهو الذي بات بشبه المؤكد انه
انه انتهى يعني حياه بنيامين نتنياهو
سياسيه انتهت وب بالتالي انت ترى انت ترى
وان
كان يعني حول الحرب او اليوم التالي او
التحقيق برايك هذا هو المخرج الذي سيفرض
نفسه في
المشهد يعني ال لجان التحقيق اعتقد انه
ايضا تكليف
مفاز عقد الازمه ليس فقط لانه كان له
علاقه بالانسحاب والانفصال عن غزه بفتره
شارون بال 2005 لانه ميري ريجف اكثر
المحتجين والتي هاجمت الليله باجتماع
الحكومه
رئيس الاركان هي كانت الناطق بلسان الجيش
وكانت جزء من المنظومه العسكريه كانت
جنرال بالجيش الاسرائيلي وكن الحرب هذا هو
سؤالي ان كان بهذا الشان او بشان الحرب
بكل هذه الخلافات برايك ما هو الحل الذي
سيفرض نفسه
الان يعني يعني بدون التدخل الامريكي ارى
ان الامور يعني معقده سواء بتسويه
الخلافات الداخليه بينهم او بما ينعكس على
مجريات الحرب وغزه ما بعد الحرب ولكن
اعتقد انه انه هذا في الحالي وان كان
مقتنعا ان انفكاك الحكومه يعني عدم عودتهم
لكني ارى ان خروج جلنت من الحكومه قريبا
سيؤدي الى بدايه نهايه هذه الحكومه والتي
بتقديري وفق كل الاستطلاعات لن تعود
بالافق القادم بعد الاخفاقات سواء بما
يتعلق باحداث تغييرات بالمنظومه القضائيه
بالعام الماضي او بالفشل الذي
يعني تعرضت له اسرائيل والذي وصف بالعار
الكبير بالسابع من اكتوبر ثم الاداره
الفاشله وفق تقييمات ثلاث اربع المجتمع
اليهودي للحكومه في ادارتها للحرب الحاليه
منذ اي اكثر من 90 يوما بالتالي يعني ارى
ان الخلافات اخره بالتصاعد في اسرائيل
وبالمناسبه هذا ينعكس سلبا على امكانيه
وقف اطلاق النار الا بتدخل امريكي فاعل
يضغط على اسرائيل وحينها اعتقد انه
الامريكي يمتلك الكثير من الاوراق لتمرير
يعني رؤيته اتجاه ما ما شكرا لك من الخليل
عادل شديد الباحث المختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي